pourquoi vous avez choisi de travailler
sur ce sujet d'être apporteur de ce
texte écoutez ce texte quand on m'a l'a
proposé ma particulièrement intéressé et
il y a une valeur je trouve qu'il y a il
a il a ressenti important sur le plan de
de la de l'émotion c'est vrai que on le
voit à chaque fois que qu'il est
présenté l'importance pour les pour les
endroits pour les familles spolier le le
l'envie d'avoir cette réparation et et
je pense la nécessité de la France et
d'autres pays de faire cette réparation
qui auprès de 80 ans et il me semble
indispensable et nécessaire un mot sur
la date puisque vous le rappeliez ça
concerne la période
33-45
or la France n'a été occupée à partir de
juin 40 il y a eu des spoliations avant
oui tout à fait il y avait déjà des des
actes de spoliation alors sans doute
beaucoup moins important que pendant la
période de l'Occupation et du
gouvernement de Vichy mais il y avait
déjà des actes donc on a on a vraiment
fait large au niveau de l'espace de de
de l'arrivée dès l'arrivée mais aussi
par rapport au pays parce que le texte
de le texte de la comment l'ordonnance
de 1945 permettait sur le plan
judiciaire de redonner des biens spolier
en France pendant la période de la
période de l'occupation donc ça nous a
permis d'élargir le spectre et de et de
de d'agir sur plusieurs périodes qui
n'étaient pas prises en compte
auparavant donc c'est une un
élargissement important alors vous le
disiez ce texte va faciliter le travail
de réparation mais ça permet aussi un
travail de mémoire vis-à-vis de ces
familles spolier qui ont été victimes de
ces persécutions antisémites tout à fait
et ce travail de mémoire est
indispensable parce que pour certaines
familles après les auditions que nous
avions nous ayons pu faites c'est
l'important c'est parfois la
valeur de l'oeuvre mais c'est aussi le
sens de cette réparation de ce de ce
travail de mémoire et de la
reconnaissance de de des actes
innommable qui ont pu avoir lieu pendant
cette période de trouble qu'est-ce qui
ressort justement de ces auditions de
préparation au débat de ce projet de loi
et de ces familles qui ont été spoliées
elle raconte un long combat pour
retrouver ses œuvres et avoir réparation
c'est parfois très long c'est pas faut
être très complexe et ça va le devenir
de plus en plus au fil des générations
qui passent et
mais je crois que au moins que les
travaux soient faits pour les recherches
de provenance et permettre aux gens aux
personnes de dire oui il y a réellement
eu un acte de spoliation et je crois que
c'est ce que les victimes veulent
entendre les familles des victimes
veulent entendre que que leur ancêtres
leurs grand-père arrière-grand-père ont
été victimes de ces de ces de ces gestes
totalement délictueux
[Musique]